foreign
hey guys I want to talk to you about
something called Original grain I wish I
made up that name but I didn't I like to
make things up and I didn't do that
original grain the company did because
they're a great company and
um look at this
look at that heavy chunk I love it I
love it right there on my wrist like
that yeah go to originalgrain.com
lifeline and use code Lifeline for a
total of 30 off they are currently
running a 20 off Black Friday well not
Black Black Friday deal right now but
using my Lincoln code will give you an
extra 10 off so that's multiple
percentages stacked on top of each other
and that makes a total of 30 off wow the
highest markdown you'll get for the
holidays really so uh look it's made of
rare rugged Bro Look at that that's good
it makes it nice it looks cool with my
tattoo larger watch face right great
blender style functionality comes with a
stopwatch Timing System and a calendar
date function the back of the watch
could be engraved personalized look it's
great for Christmas it's great for gifts
right weddings birthdays anniversaries
whatever perfect to pair with uh the
Broward silver tungsten ring also
sunglasses back in stock look at your
boy with them right on right here
out they were sold out no I know but
they got them back in stock and they
sold out they sold out after last our
last ads and uh use the link in the code
that's code Lifeline at
originalgrain.com lifeline
Lifeline is the code to get 30 off
site-wide wow
whether you are shopping for yourself or
someone special Adam and Eve will have
the perfect gifts and with an amazing
deal you guys can you get just about any
item at fifty percent off plus free
shipping you can get every wow almost
any item yeah dude when you uh use this
podcast exclusive code Lifeline at
checkout
l-i-f-e-l-i-n-e our podcast listeners
will get 50 off almost any item that's
anything you know that's like a new toy
slippery Lube you get a slippery lube
and really almost anything you could
possibly desire also when it shows up
it's gonna be discreet it's not going to
expose it's not going to let you know
let your neighbors know what the deal is
yeah it doesn't matter what you choose
it'll be in discrete packaging not only
we save money on gas movies and date
night dinner's out but this is the item
that will continue to save your money
deliver tons of fun and satisfaction you
get more pleasure in the bedroom it's
the gift that keeps giving just treat
yourself treat your partner baby life is
too short to not enjoy go to
adamandeve.com select any one item use
code Lifeline
l-i-f-e-l-i-n-e this is an exclusive
offer specific to this podcast so be
sure to support our show and use this
code Lifeline to get you not just the 50
off but also the 100 free shipping so
that's 50 and then 100 wow code Lifeline
go to adamandeve.com right now
adamandeve.com baby
Lifeline is an advice show for
entertainment purposes only if you need
real help or advice please seek a
therapist or licensed professional
[Music]
all audio
okay
why are you being like a I want to know
have you ever seen the rain wow I'm good
remember when I used to call Chris our
producer Reigns yeah you don't do that
anymore I don't do that anymore why
don't you do that anymore because I'll
tell you why I'm not a [ __ ] prick
like we're not supposed to swear in the
beginning oh because I'm not sure an
effing a mother effing prick like I was
when I was 19. well why you did that for
a long time dude yeah because you want
to explain what that was about yeah I
was gonna say no you I don't know I
don't know it started it started
explain what it's about working baby
I wanna know and now see now all right
okay see now [ __ ] he's doing it like
this trying to change the thing you see
anything like this all right so
um that's it when people do Shazam and
they're like here we go
yeah I do that it's like dude it it'll
work the sound goes everywhere I
unfortunately so if I'm like I want to
know can you ever read I don't even
remember rain I don't need to do that
you know what that is that's the guy who
sings that what is the noise
well that's annoying okay that's okay
for audio
should it should have made coffee before
we did the thing didn't make coffee
before we did the thing so instead of
that he's doing it while we're doing it
and there's gonna be a sound in the
background now that's clear and obvious
that he shouldn't have done that am I
right 100 okay great that's all now that
being said we got interrupted talking
about rains now why did you used to call
them Reigns and rains man guys I used to
call them Marines because why that's
what I want to know Chris I want to know
why you calling them Reigns and rains
man guys Range band guys was my personal
invention
for my fantasy uh baseball team name we
have a producer we've known him since
childhood my brother used to call our
produce also he's turning on the sink
great so much noise I Wanna Know why I
turn on this thing it also make
[Applause]
Omega is on an elephant comes in so
[ __ ] oh he's doing it dude
I'll do that how about when you don't
think about how you can move stuff yeah
yeah you're just like oh well that's in
the way even though it's light you can't
go like this one
like that that was what you're doing to
turn his fingers don't go that way you
go yeah you know
yeah yeah exactly dude so all right so
why did you call him Reigns I called him
Reigns I don't know why you don't
remember why oh I know why I used to
make a joke that I thought
he looked like Dallas Reigns The the
weatherman oh my God I mean is there
anyone that looks less like Dallas
Raines no Uzi vert but I also got
everyone else on board with it so we
would all be like oh dude you look like
that guy what's his name and then
everyone said it
and so then everybody
saw how much it got him mad
that we said that even though he's super
[ __ ] handsome that guy uh I mean and
he's got the crazy good streaks in his
hair all right uh and he you know he
lives close to our relatives and stuff
so the thing is he got mad and so it
perpetuated it but then we became adults
and stopped because we realized that's
like basically bullying you know not
really I mean just calling him some
handsome newscaster guy I know but yeah
he would get mad yeah okay cool then he
stopped getting mad and was like that
only held a mirror up to our faces and
we were like why are we bullies you know
hmm interesting so why am I a bully so
basically Reigns calling him Reigns
helped made you look inward yeah why am
I a bully why are you a bully a student
film
student film a bully
student film I love you despite your
flaws so bad so listen
um so listen you used to call them rains
which is fine but what I want to know is
that that lasted for I mean maybe a
decade forever yeah so why did it stop
one day it stopped or what no it just
fizzled out I grew into an adult and
stopped saying it it was stupid and you
still call Mike sharp ikebarf I called
Mike sharp eichbarf but that has that
has evolved into Ichabod barvik nugen
okay so what so why do you call him
Ichabod bar vignogen well first of all
you're still an adult and you've grown
yeah so why would you call him ichaboda
he's in barfing nugen he's in my phone
is like about barvik nugen okay and then
it's and then you know where it says
like company name yeah I did stupidest
[ __ ] TM okay okay so you're still a
bully didn't realize much but that's in
my own phone I'm not like telling him
right this is a reminder oh he's calling
me what he's gonna say might be stupid
as [ __ ] right okay it's just a warning
myself so so yeah so like bar
Productions you know was first because
Mike sharp like barf is very simple and
easy so but it sounded a little too
short so I made it sound like very sort
of Airy and old-timey Ichabod barfic
nougat okay now also then sometimes to
get you back he calls you hat he calls
me hat well now he calls me house I
think about Mike is that he's stupid as
[ __ ] and comes up with the worst
comebacks what so I'll call him Ike
boyfriend he'll be like oh how's Julia
why house I don't there's no reason at
all and she just does it but it's also
really funny and he knows it so now he
does it more you know because it's he
knows how bad it is yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
I mean house Delia house Dalia is so
sick actually I'm gonna name a kid house
yeah you should you should wow man
that's absolutely incredible thank you
what'd you do today uh so here's what I
did I woke up
the [ __ ] Pretenders I woke up when I
wake up
I woke up and I saw my dog it doesn't
have to be actual every single second no
and then I and then I saw my dog and I
said hey Jenny you mean
what's your dog's name Charlie why'd you
say Jimmy I didn't I said hi Jenny I
mean dude Anthony just burped so loud so
it was so good it was right after right
before the episode Matt said Matt said
man Anthony you're so quiet yeah it was
and then he just goes he was offended by
me saying he's quiet what do you think
is worth burping or farting
uh I know mine a loud one is a burp
burps or disgusting
[ __ ] face Anthony get that [ __ ] away
from my face dude farting I can deal
with burping I cannot deal here's
especially why you can make an argument
that a fart is uncontrollable no you can
okay yes dude you could sometimes you
think it's gonna come out quiet and it
doesn't with a burp
it's just like quiet where birds are
worse than big ones yeah big ones but
those are worse
oh so gross dudes just like Imagining
the acid yeah it's
those [ __ ] Bert those UNS burps yeah
they're terrible they're disgusting
they're so disgusting Anthony is [ __ ]
disgusting
outrageous I I burp only when I drink
heavy carbonation it's in private that's
okay the wet ones are fine but like the
[ __ ] it is in private burps are for
private
anybody that just goes but is disgusting
and a [ __ ] ape is absolutely
disgusting okay
the other thing is I used to have a
roommate in college who used to burp all
the time it was almost like he had a
sickness where he would just non-stop
burped and he would and he would rub his
belly when he did it oops why doesn't
this work he would rub his belly when he
did it everyone's listening to you okay
just he just that's disgusting
that's disgusting and then even Hawk
loogies into pieces of tissue and
sometimes if he wasn't close enough to
the trash you just put it on his desk
oh God that's disgusting
ew everyone like his Buddha okay that's
disgusting look if you have a question
click the link in the description below
or go to watch lifeline.com you can get
one-on-one advice sessions with Matt at
mattdelia.com and those have been going
gangbusters and all the great new
Lifeline merch is at lifelinemerch.com I
will be in New York I will be in San
Diego I will be in Seattle I will be in
Lakeland I will be in
um
of Lakeland Florida I will be in
Jacksonville I will be in uh Seattle
Portland I will be in Chicago go to
chrisley.com San Antonio Texas Sugar
Land New Orleans New York these are all
the Kansas City Springfield look at all
these Tulsa wow Midland Austin Jesus
Cincinnati Ohio Columbus Ohio Boise
Idaho Minneapolis Boise and absolutely
you know a lot of dates but gotta
collect them bags you know what I mean
that's pretty pimping bad collector you
know look at my roommate though you know
what he the thing he did that I thought
was the most unacceptable was none of
those things what was it not Hawking
loogies and leaving him around not
burping not rubbing his belly severed
heads in the freezer went to a cold play
concert already bad came back yeah I
asked him how it was and he said pretty
grubbing
all right
at that point I knew
this man is a bad person to have around
in my Orbit dude they cannot be in my
life anymore so how was it
and I said I said I said what do you
mean pretty grubbing did you [ __ ] eat
it like what are you talking about how
is how it's so funny to be like the
[ __ ]
and he's just like dude this is grubbing
I mean yeah that's literally what it was
that's great that he was like how is it
you know how Copenhagen he's like pretty
grubbing and that's what I knew in
freezeman yep I could never hang out
with him ever again yeah yeah he said
Coldplay was pretty grubbing and then
when I made him feel bad about it like
put him on the spot about it he just
went like this
back to rubbing his belly it was like
his nervous tick
uh honestly dude
Coldplay is pretty grubbing what's the
other about it they're kind of grubbing
yeah what's the other one that goes man
not the uh yellow what's the other big
one the clocks one what's the clocks one
they have a bunch of books and clocks
one I don't talk one to go oh it's the
one that's kind of fast
[Applause]
this is what the producer did I said
what did they go it goes like this
yeah
didn't even look up yep didn't for a
second dude
yo hey
dude imagine so sick it was such a
baller move imagine if you were in a
meeting and just some guy
like I totally isolated no you're gonna
go ask for a raise you walk in he's just
no no what if you asked for the raisin
then he did that yeah yeah you know I've
been thinking I work really hard for you
guys I was wondering you know other
companies pay more could I possibly
maybe get a raise
that would doesn't even look up at you
yeah playing Wordle well the biggest
baller on the face of the planet outside
stack okay
cool yeah dude I mean I just think
that's pretty grubbing honestly to be
doing it it's grubbing and when it's
grubbing it's grubbing okay um I oh oh
oh this is the other thing I don't
bursting I don't do oh oh oh I don't do
the thing on anymore oh I just real
quickly after somebody says something I
say something offensive and says you're
looking kind of fat in that shirt today
all right man you just go like why even
is Anthony laughing at that because it's
great because he understands his
greatness all right so okay yeah you
look fat in that yeah yeah dude you're a
pro you're fat pull yes dude all right
all right worst life coach yes
[Laughter]
[Applause]
Tony Robbins with his big ass face Tony
Robbins has the deepest voice you can't
even understand the words he's saying
dude he's just like well you got to
break up with your girl do it right now
wow that's such a good impression right
now and for everybody three thousand
people call right now Tony Robbins voice
sounds like when one piece of Earth
separates from the another piece of
Earth so I used to be California and now
on two states dude wow that's good huh
that's what it is I'd never know I could
do until now so I was in I was the San
Fernando Valley and now uh I'm two parts
okay I was in San Francisco Valley that
was one part and now two parts I'm North
San Fernando Valley and I'm South San
Fernando Valley gonna wake up tomorrow
and be like what's my voice search yeah
I have dude it's gonna be the Tony
Robbins the person gotta wake up call
plunge that's what I do I start my day
with cold punches you gotta shock your
body ever gotta shock your body because
you got to be out of your element
everybody that talks about cold plunges
listen here's the deal you want to raise
you want to talk about a cold plunge you
gotta talk elsewhere about that I don't
want to hear about your culture it's a
bit like the how yoga used to be you're
being a vegan I don't want you to
recommend a cold plunge to me I want you
to go away talk about the cold plunge to
someone else what do you ask me what I
think about cold lunch what do you think
about cold lunch pretty grubbing
yeah well then you would like them and
then we would not be brothers anymore
because
plunge pretty pretty grubbing anything
with cold in the beginning yeah
um all right well yeah and I all busted
pretty good pretty good pretty Robin
yeah that's right yeah
um you know I really uh I really uh
enjoy the banter I really enjoy our
[ __ ] I really also enjoy taking
submissions but I gotta say sometimes
when we just go and it's having a good
time and we're just kind of feeling it
you know that's what I like yeah me too
man I mean I like it I know the show's
Lifeline I love the guests but I love
the banters too you know yeah all right
uh and that's just how it is
okay so let's go
um let's go into a into it right now and
our first submission
all right well Matt said he wants a lot
of details I'm keeping it wrong my baby
okay good here we go in an airplane
Hangar so to start off I'm an old school
born in Chicago Sicilian
just a piece of [ __ ] okay and I'm only
22. and I know Chris you're the youngest
baby of all babies but not exactly right
I feel like you're literally me so
and this sensitive ass sappy-ass world
that we live in especially with kids my
age and me being like the opposite of
everything the status quo is okay I just
want to know how you keep that like
strength and that uh momentum you know I
I feel like I keep getting like dragged
down just for having my own opinions and
thoughts and I'm [ __ ] sick of it so
just a good old discussion you know
starter y'all can help me out just a
little bit
okay so here's the thing you're very
young and you described this sort of
sensation of being pulled down by the
world maybe or by people around you you
know what that's called that's called
life wow okay let's go life okay that's
what life is wow the worst Tony Robbins
you get dragged down oh really are you
well that welcome to life okay yeah okay
so you open the door and there's life
right that's what happened okay so you
think you're you're gonna hit the grain
you're looking like-minded people all
right you can't find him you open the
door okay hey guess who guess who just
came over life all right so life's over
it's not what are you gonna do life's in
your house right you gotta live with
life right yeah
this is life wow okay girlfriend break
up with her okay that's Tony's advice
now Chris oh Chris is leaving okay bye
Chris I think honestly that you uh
you're fine relax
you're 22 and everything's gonna be okay
down that's life that's what happens it
happens to everybody it happened to me
sometimes it happens at 25 sometimes it
happens way too late sometimes it
happens at 22. sometimes it happens when
you're 16 you know you get kicked out of
the house whatever the [ __ ] going on
you have crazy parents
um but yeah this is how you feel this is
how you're supposed to feel everything
is by Design it's fine but find
like-minded people
chill have a good time you're young
experience it smoke that stick yikki
yeah right definitely that chocolate tie
I'm not in condoning weed but get your
card get your card and maybe do it
legally
right okay eat gummies do whatever the
[ __ ] okay and uh
you know I don't know what maybe the
problem is is that she's being like uh
too much for her friends or something or
too much in this world she feels like
she's too much like she's saying things
that are offending people I don't know I
get the sense she doesn't seem to have a
filter yeah she doesn't seem to have a
filter and you know I'm a comedian I'm
okay I make a living off of that often a
good quality but not always it is often
a good quality but not always I will say
so maybe
every now and then just take a look at
yourself and what you might be doing
right
um also like you're young and just chill
the thing about being young it sucks to
when I remember when I was young people
would always say oh you're so young
you'll figure it out I hated that
nothing nothing I hated nothing more
than that but there's one part of that
side but yeah that carries weight in
retrospect and it's it's this
when you're young the amount of things
you've experienced are just naturally
less than someone who's older because
they haven't lived as long it's just
like there's no way around that and
because of that significance of things
that are less significant in truth feel
more significant because of the
condensed amount of experiences that
they've had okay so what I'm saying is
to expound on what I was saying before
about that's just life
it feels crazy and chaotic and wild and
dramatic when you're experiencing it
when you're 20 right but in truth it's
just another day for an adult yep and
you're new to that so what I'm saying is
get used to it yep and it's like that's
life you gotta turn the other cheek okay
what the hell was that's life you said
that's life but what did you do that's
the Frank Sinatra song no it wasn't not
what you did that's life sometimes you
gotta turn the other cheek you gotta
walk into myself
utterly fell apart but my point is uh
yeah
um it's allowed but uh yeah I think that
that's what you should do what I said I
like Coke and I don't mean the drug you
know
wow uh great great today great to meet
you and uh we really hope you figure it
out but I think mainly right now don't
even worry about it yes you're just you
you're gonna be you yes this is the time
you get to be unapologetically you when
you're done too right yes you're not
famous not like you have to watch what
you say really but every now and then
just look a little bit Inward and be
like did I really hurt anybody's
feelings yes all right so that's cool
dude one time you were talking about you
were talking about being young one time
when I was in I was in a um
uh what are called little league and our
coach his last name was young and he had
a kid on the team that was named
something young I remember this was her
last name and I told Matt travenin our
neighbor Jersey yeah oh wow so my friend
that um they made us sing forever young
because that last name was young what do
you mean oh oh you made it up yeah okay
yeah and and he believed me and I and I
said like before we we go out and we
play we would have to put our hands in
the thing and go forever young oh my God
and he was like that's crazy dude that's
her last name why would they make you do
that I was like I don't know what that's
what made me do I never told him pick up
the dumbest things man why do we do that
I don't know just testing the limits I
guess so the testing the limits of what
we can get away with that's what
Calvin's doing right now and how's that
going for him
uh it's I'm a sucker bro he came up to
me and he goes like this hey Dad can I
ask you for an ice cream favor and I was
like oh my God those are good favors oh
my God it was so cute he wanted ice
cream and that's what and yeah I gave
him ice cream how could I not he was
trying to be polite he was like I could
see these motors work like I want to get
the ice cream so I got to be polite
about it he thought that's how to be
polite hey Dad can I ask you for an ice
cream favor and it was the cutest thing
ever it's not wrong that is designing
cute and I gave him [ __ ] ice cream
because it was so cute it would be cute
even if he was like 23 that's just cute
oh down the line what's up Matt can I
can I ask you an ice cream flavor yeah
well not if you asked it like that but
yeah proper like excuse me uh can I ask
you an ice cream favorite I ask you an
ice cream flavor see that's cute yeah
you're right yeah I've been cute even
though I'm I was on 42. yeah wow I'm 42.
that's crazy yeah you know why because
you remember when I was seven uh barely
remember when I was 11. uh yes isn't
that crazy yes dude that is so crazy you
remember when I was 11. yeah I'm gonna
absolutely kick my ass I remember two
let's talk about a little bit outside no
but how we had so much fun as kids yeah
I did right yeah I mean the best that I
remember time just having the generally
of the best time was when we would be in
the car for long periods of time and you
and I would do this thing where
I was the audience and I would say I bet
you can't make me laugh five times in 30
seconds and the clock would stop for the
duration of a laugh so if I laughed
really hard
it could potentially ruin the whole
possibility so once I regained a
straight face or at least stopped
laughing the clock would start again
yeah uh on the three two one count right
yeah yeah and so almost invariably every
single time we would do it
by the time
one or two seconds came around you
already had four
so it was like we would CR I would
create this Cliffhanger scenario of like
is he gonna get me and it would be so
hard trying to hold it in yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yes I did it you know but rarely do you
remember that you would do it too and
you would always get me with one thing
do you remember what you would always
get me to laugh at with
you don't remember this I don't know
maybe you're gonna remember it since I
tell you is it something physical yeah
yeah kind of yeah what was it oh the
face
dude I couldn't I couldn't not laugh at
that dude you just get closer and closer
and closer and I wouldn't be laughing
you just on my face dude I would be
dying that is so weird isn't that from
nerds Revenge the Nerds I mean I don't
know if that's one of the guys laughs
yeah dude it was so [ __ ] funny wow
such idiots kids are such dumb asses wow
I know so tall look up look at the image
of us so tall
people think you're short of them you're
like one inch shorter than me yeah but
like to be perfectly honest not even one
inch so watch your mouth but uh yeah I
know whenever I look at the screen I
look like I'm seven inches shorter than
you your [ __ ] is like three or four
inches shorter than mine though no my
[ __ ] is actually I'm two inches shorter
than I look standing up but because my
[ __ ] is so long it pushes me up the head
of the penis touches the ground and
pushes me up two inches such
a [ __ ] dumb lie no it's true okay
well anyway at least we're hitting the
hard-hitting issues let's go to another
submission let's go we've done one and
it's been 25 minutes in the show okay
I'll get i'll get my babies
I love you bro
so I've been sober for over four years
there you go
I've got a wife and kid which takes up a
lot of my time but I'm still struggling
to find enjoyment in a lot of things
sure yeah without drinking yep which is
sad yeah uh all the hobbies that I get
interested in are still like shitty ones
like gaming and then I feel like I get
addicted to gaming and then I'll draw
I'll try drawing but then I'll just get
addicted to that and I'll just be doing
that too much
I honestly feel like I'll get addicted
to any [ __ ] thing that I do so she's
what do you guys do in your spare time
to have fun it's over
I don't know if you guys can help me out
that'd be great thank you I mean working
first of all those things are all better
than drinking yeah so gaming and drawing
I wouldn't necessarily count that out
but I know what he's talking about he's
not getting that high from [ __ ]
drinking of course that he is from
drinking them yeah
um I was listening to a thing the other
day online where a guy was addicted to
porn and the fact is that this doctor
was saying he wasn't addicted to porn
necessarily he's addicted to the
dopamine hit that he got from porn which
of course we understand that but uh he
traded it for boxing and now he [ __ ]
boxes and he gets that dopamine hit in a
much healthier way and isn't wasting his
time watching porn ruining his life but
um you don't get to come that way right
so boxing doesn't boxing doesn't end in
bukuki it never does so
um close enough though yeah your face
could be a mess the but yeah it's just
it's tough man addiction is very tough
you got to keep going and trying to do
this for your kids and your wife
um and it's a struggle man it's a
constant struggle it's a struggle for me
addiction is tough and it is very
[ __ ] hard and um you know like I
always tell I totally think I gotta get
told last episode but you know you got
to think about what you're grateful
about that's the opposite of this [ __ ]
man that [ __ ] darkness that demon the
opposite of that is what you're grateful
about man because that's what you're
living for you're not living for this
[ __ ] demon you're living for what
you're grateful for and you are grateful
for the most beautiful thing on earth
that's your family okay I would also say
you open the door that's life you
talking about Hobbies you're talking
about things that keep you busy passions
in life that are outside of you know
family and all that uh
I think it's best to have a hobby or
whatever you want to call it or even if
you have to be addicted to something
have it be something that you can see
the progress as you go like gaming is
not that you know like these are just
things you do and then they're over and
then you go back to your life and then
you come back and play again and it's
just the same thing over and over again
yeah but I know a guy who actually got
really into like working out yeah and
like he can physically see the games
yeah you know and and that is sort of in
in place of
uh the drugs and alcohol that he was
taking it's night and day I mean one
thing is amazing for you right and you
can see the the improvements every
single time you do the other one is
killing you so like I would suggest even
if it's not something on your body it
can be anything that you can see like
even learning like what about reading
like those things think about all the
things you've learned since you picked
up that book it can be this dopamine hit
it's like you start feeling like you
understand the way the world works and
that's like a big sort of it's a really
good sensation to feel like you're
learning about something you know yeah
it's on your own and now you can you
don't need to go to school for that [ __ ]
learn about whatever you want dude it's
[ __ ] a click away yeah you know yeah
no excuse anymore yeah everybody should
be so [ __ ] smart and yet and yet
careful with that addiction man it's so
[ __ ] Insidious you know it's so hard
but what he's doing I feel for you you
got four [ __ ] years under your belt
belth belt and uh you know keep keep
moving bro that's impress is really
impressive dude congratulations come
back in another four years let us know
yep also had so many [ __ ] layers on
he did he was cold yeah okay all right
let's do next one
hey guys so I need some advice on how to
appear smarter than what I actually am I
have a fear or insecurity whatever you
would call it of being in a conversation
with somebody them asking me a question
and me just saying I don't know and the
conversation just ending there
um
so my advice
the advice that I would need is hey I
guess should I just own the fact that I
don't know whatever it is that's being
talked about
I just
be confident in that or
do you guys have any phrases or things
that I should say in the middle of a
situation like that something that I
don't know so it doesn't look like I'm
completely clueless oh my God let me
know bro you're so much ahead of
everyone else people talk about [ __ ]
they don't even know about I have a
whole I made a living off this [ __ ] man
you are so it's so dope to be the way
you are is to just not I don't know
that's so awesome man I wish more people
would say they don't [ __ ] know yeah I
mean that's what everybody always wishes
for the reason they don't is because
they don't want to be the one that
doesn't know but if everybody stop
pretending everybody would be a lot
happier because everybody realize oh
you're dumb too oh you're dumb too yeah
oh we're all [ __ ] dumb this is
amazing just say oh nobody wants to do
that yeah I mean it's okay it's totally
fine to say I don't know because you
already look better than the people who
are putting forth opinions that aren't
even based on facts those people [ __ ]
suck but everybody can tell those people
fell asleep on the microphone
um make them feel bad for it they ask
you a question go like this I don't know
yeah why are you asking me that so
personal me for dude personal the
capital of Florida is so personal what
Tallahassee who cares I don't know why
would you make me say the word
Tallahassee is it is it it is
Tallahassee it is yeah
Don't Clap for yourself it's nothing
knowing that is nothing dude
wow wow the ego for knowing the capital
of Florida at age 42 you know Tyler
freaking hassy dude I didn't even know
well obviously you did I I didn't know I
just kind of fired it out there I just
used myself it was in your brain I do it
the same way I know that sometimes the
guy's Australian when he calls in and
before he even speaks okay I just got
the gift of here he's got women's
intuition oh wow hurt your hands so bad
when you put that haircut yeah do it but
I think that that's uh I think that oh
that's a drama
I do it uh yeah you don't know and
that's the [ __ ] dude I love not knowing
stuff I don't know so much stuff
sometimes we'll try to dummy stuff like
this I don't want to know because I want
to know I don't know no no you're
halfway right it's good to say you don't
know if you don't know but then ask
them what they're talking about they can
inform you then you learn then you know
more and then go like this you're
probably lying
don't trust anybody do it actually no
that sucks trust no one like Tupac
nothing is your annoying about him then
you when you say like well how do you
know that that doesn't sound right it's
like well it is right you know and
you're like no it doesn't sound right
you know I think you're on a website
that website's fake yeah exactly that's
basically what you do yeah that's what I
do yeah yeah fake news okay I don't know
man I feel like you know own it
um honestly Yoki Doodle Dandy look at
this [ __ ] guy dude okay he's on swole
yeah he's very cool he's [ __ ] only
he's so big and his clock is so big yeah
the guy is a [ __ ] absolute
what is he's good at what is he good at
he's good at you can do a full black
backflip bodybuilding dude the guy is
just Yoki Doodle Dandy from the [ __ ]
neck down okay all right let's do it
all right finally show been a final
congratulations for years absolutely
love you guys so nice my question is
what do you do when your mates are a
little bit cheap my best mate love him
to bits don't want to change him really
but
he doesn't ever want to spend any money
on food like we'll all want to go out
we'll all want to go to restaurant and
have like a nice time and I'm someone
who really believes that like it's worth
spending a bit of money for a nice meal
yeah dude and his mentality is I've got
beef and rice at home so why would I go
out and spend money
probably not gonna be able to change him
now beef well what do you think I should
do is there anything you think I can do
to get him to change and to try to like
actually enjoy life a little bit and
spend his money anyway love you guys
hope to hear from you thanks bro dude
you know you always want to eat beans
and rice you won't go out and get a
[ __ ] good meal man don't stop being a
cheapskate dude I feel drinking beans
you know honestly I think that being uh
cheap is such a horrid quality yeah dude
even if you're broke which I've been
many a time in my life
pay money for things that are worth
money and never stop doing things even
if you gotta [ __ ] dude I've had like
seven cents in my bank account so sad
seven cents so so sad it's unreal okay
uh but you know uh I've also been in the
opposite situation but I've had
trillions of dollars insurance no but
the uh uh you never stop
be not like idiotic with money but like
error on the side of loose with money
not tight dude nobody wants to be around
someone that is super tight with money
well they obviously do though because
they keep inviting them out that's the
thing he doesn't even go the guy doesn't
go so he doesn't even have a chance to
be tight with money so he's not so all
right so so basically this guy wants the
other guy to be like coming out with
them and also
springing for it yeah
um maybe just tell them like yo
you're like losing out on life
like what's another what's 15 pounds or
bucks or Euros or whatever the [ __ ] it
is for you like
you're gonna look back in your life and
be like I never hung out with my friends
because I was worried about saving
twelve dollars I don't know I don't know
also times are so [ __ ] tough though
too I know but you gotta mix it up a
little bit dude yeah you got to give up
that yaper every once in a while for a
good time you're gonna give up that
April you're spending money to live dude
he's not spending money for the meal
somebody will be like oh that steak is
so expensive it's like yeah but like
you're paying for the time out with your
friends your family the people you like
and care about I'm also just being a
steak I'm also gonna make up that if
he's friends with them the guy's not
dirt broke like maybe he's just being
cheap you know what I'm saying like that
is it yeah but I'm saying baby he has
the money I know yeah I didn't even
think about that yeah yeah that's okay
so if he has the money then then it's
like bro no no no come on man we got to
live especially if like you're in a
group of friends and you have more dude
spread it around be the one that like
goes broke spend it on your boys MC
Hammer for whatever not to that extent
but that's what I'm saying yeah that is
what he did people like Hammer go hammer
go and he went and now he's [ __ ]
broke dude now he's gotta go get a loan
yeah he would perform it like you know a
high school graduation if you paid him
wow you know 2500 go hammer go hammer go
go go go go and they meant to Wells
Fargo to ask for a loan that's what they
mean all right cool sweat coming all
over my cheeks at a week stand uh that
harder than I ever did before when they
go Gotta make time but if I go and they
go and then when they were there
instead of saying the RS like he was
Mexican the amount of sounds you made
yeah that go along with the amount of
words that's very strange you said made
so many sounds so few words here we go
and now see now it's my turn to talk
right so you talk for a while I let you
talk now it's my turn to talk to school
just keep doing it right so now the way
we're gonna do it is I'm gonna talk
right just a little bit and then you
talk again okay go ahead okay I forgot
what I'm gonna say go ahead he goes
harder than I ever did before that's
what he said
yeah
too legit to legit
goes legit wow made it so bad
that was legit
yeah that's legit okay it was legit
those Legit to Quit hey hey those legit
wow no it would be like it would be
those Legit to Quit I I yeah
the slight difference it was legit those
legit I I like that's the only word they
would change yeah those two I don't know
oh I know that I'm just saying what if
the song really was that it's in uh
what is what is here he's looking it up
what's legit in Spanish oh wow it's
legit
it's right there dude
it was legit my quit hey hey legitima
yeah
and then quit we do not quit I don't
know probably like
Thursday
doesn't have the same ring to it
doesn't have the simmering so bad
abandon our eye dos legitimo does
and I want you to stop
trying to stop so bad that's the
greatest part about this podcast that
has ever happened dude and what's
interesting is if that's true about I
want you to stop has to be the [ __ ]
absolute title of this okay okay here we
go look at this guy let's go
hey Matt day Chris what's up uh
starting a new job in a couple of weeks
and I haven't told the old work yet ah
I just don't know how to go I'll be out
Kelly
my current boss should I
tell him all the real reasons
why I'm leaving right or should I I and
say it's just for money
so if I don't like the new job or I have
a fail safe and I can come back or
should I
tell him all the real reasons and
burn the breach and just be stuck with
the usual
good question if you think you even if
there's a very tiny chance if you think
there's a possibility that you would
ever return to that company just quit
yeah say you're moving on for a little
bit of better pay that you had a great
time here uh but do not burn the bridge
there's if there's no reason to and it's
even remotely possible you returned he
said something about returning dude just
don't just don't don't be don't burn
bridges yeah yeah don't I mean there's
also there's also there's also a way to
make sure to oh my god dude
oh my God look at that
yeah
I mean that's too many of them
yeah yeah
um
not the same ring um so look
um
I yeah also you have to look out for
your
your career that's a different thing
than your personal life you probably
personally want to [ __ ] jump down his
throat but your career would beg to
differ about how you would want to
handle this your career is something
that you have to look for first of all
legally
second of all you might need a letter of
recommendation or something like that I
just think it's best to just
fully agree bygones yeah let it go
better job Let It Go yep let bygones be
around is that what it is let burgers be
bygones it is yeah so
um yeah I just think that uh Los bagones
that's um yeah I think that that's what
you do good but you've got some
Steely blue eyes yeah he's got that
beard too that is a man that guy almost
broke our [ __ ] camera he's pure man
that guy was it South African or
Australian I honestly couldn't tell I
didn't even hear the accent oh okay okay
all right cool making me look bad but
okay okay well next one
wow
hey guys what's up my co-worker slash
good friend
wipes his ass back to front
and I want you to tell him that he's a
piece of [ __ ] for that because that's
not right
and if you're a guy you're getting it on
your balls dude this is hey you know
what that's a great idea getting your
own [ __ ] on your balls that's a great
way to do that
yeah I mean you don't have to test it
out because like he's not because these
are he if he's pushing it that's big
trouble if he's pulling it at least he's
getting some sort of control because he
goes back to front though I understand
but I'm saying you can either go in
between your legs or over your back if
you're going over your back you're
pushing it and of course okay going what
did you say but of course no I said Jeff
Gordon but if you're going it like this
you're hooking into it and pulling it
out with your finger and I kind of
understand that move you probably get it
a little bit so you're saying you go in
between the legs yeah and put and like
dig it out
okay but go backwards because there's
nothing there so you go backwards and
you just push it out
no you wipe your butt front to back from
front to back right would be really
weird if you went front to back from
here you just go you just push it
yeah that would be very strange like
this so number one
who raised to back around your back yes
number two
I say back to front around the front
between your legs yeah so that's what
he's doing he's doing the number two way
we don't know that well probably number
three
behind your back no number three between
the legs
pushing front to back yeah number four
is absolutely behind the back pushing
back to front which is what I pictured I
mean if the guy's doing that he's got
severe [ __ ] problems and here's the
thing you're right maybe about the one
two three four yeah but only ever do the
one yeah I do agree what's the second
best way to yeah whatever it's like you
know what's the second best way to
breathe oxygen whoa through your mouth
or nose is one but it's two I mean
underwater yeah exactly yeah underwater
you split get an oxygen tank hook it up
to your mouth yeah you can also just
breathe yeah yeah I think that that's
trouble dude I think that you should
mainly only do one wiping the way you do
it and that's crazy also that was one of
those ones that secretly it secretly was
him
so I got this buddy uh so I got this
buddy uh you know and he looks a lot
like me but it's not me 100 totally not
me um I think that that's crazy I didn't
even know that people did that to be
honest I've never heard of it because
you because it's so counterintuitive
yeah it's so gross it's interesting
though like if you had like if you were
raising a daughter you'd have to keep a
mind about that like I I have a son and
you go back to front but you wouldn't do
that with a daughter right you'd have to
go back go back to front what the hell's
wrong with you yeah when you wipe when I
wipe my son's butt oh oh oh I see yeah
but as a girl a woman if she goes poop
like a little baby to a one-year-old a
one-year-old woman okay one year old one
or a woman you go front to back you
gotta go back otherwise it goes inside
the you know what I mean maybe yeah but
maybe with a boy it's like there's no
real risk because there's nothing I I
don't know what the hell do I know but
you know what I'm saying though right uh
yeah I do okay I think it's a good thing
to not talk about right now though oh
you're saying about I don't want to
think about yeah oh you're saying that
you go back front to back anyway yeah
yeah just always go front to back if
you're wiping your own butt period full
stop never do anything else if you do
anything else because I don't do that
with my son but that's you doing it to
him yeah right understood okay cool
figured it out
once this is your books hey Chris and
Matt Huckleberry and I are coming out of
the Tall Grass to ask you this question
and we're gonna get specific with it
nice so I have a best friend of over
three and a half years who last year
went from a busted up Honda Accord to an
obnoxiously large Jeep Rubicon oh boy
this thing has a wench and a gun safe oh
none of which he knows how to use let
alone has any need for since we both
live in central Los Angeles right and
the ego boost it is given this guy is
beyond whoa so my question to you is do
you have any insults good digs to
playfully take him down to Peg because
he needs it it's it's a lot
love you guys stay funny so he got
thanks so he got uh he had a busted up
Honda Accord then got a Rubicon and it's
got a gun safe in it and some what else
did uh wench what is a wedding yeah what
that is I also don't even know what why
does it have a gun safe in it a wench is
those things uh it's not even on a winch
is uh
thing that you use to pull something
else from your car oh I got it wound up
rope I thought it was somebody that
works at Medieval Times
uh so hey wench can I have remember when
you were a kid you can call them lunch
you know even as a kid I was like no
that's I don't want to do that yeah yeah
when can I be so insecure about it
Excuse Me Miss wench when can I have a
more turkey please
uh okay and then what about the gun
thing yeah just tell them dude relax all
you did was get a new car anybody can do
that yeah oh guy hey you're different
now yeah oh hey guy you're different now
you don't take [ __ ] yeah you don't slip
and fall sometimes you don't eat turkey
sandwiches every now and then you don't
know
front to back yeah dude yeah [ __ ] out of
here I mean he's acting like he like did
something really cool and special no you
no he didn't oh God look at the gun safe
for the [ __ ]
dude hey guy
I want to know if the car came with the
gun safe yeah I guess it did that's
probably an option that's so stupid he's
in central Los Angeles look unsafe dude
you get pulled over gonna get [ __ ]
shot yeah dude uh all right here's
here's the snap the clap back
every time he says something or you know
Intimates that he's special because he
has this car
all always say all you did was buy a car
that is available to everyone in the
world who has mentioned she got a better
version of that car that'd be hilarious
yeah right I mean just just reiterate
that it is it is a non thing him buying
a car is a non-thing yeah how about this
whenever he says something and or does
something say well how does your car
feel about that
he says what is it well because it's so
important to you you [ __ ] loser and
then spin move out of there that's good
there you go yeah I take back mine
that's good yeah he didn't even know how
to use the gun safe dude that's
hilarious why we even pay for that
feature you know you pay more he's
Ballin dude
I mean he's pimp and pimping but
all right you want to do another one I
guess so yeah here we go let's see what
we got wow me in an alternate universe
no [ __ ] uh
he's still talking don't do it again his
mustache is afraid of the middle of his
nose what are you laughing at which part
the first part yeah and you're my
favorite person slash comedian of all
time hell yeah dude Matt I love you too
man I love congratulations but I just
wanted to get in touch with you guys and
see if you guys had any advice for me
basically next semester of college I'm
going to be moving into a two-bedroom
apartment with my roommate who's been my
best friend since high school
um and I didn't read the lease well
enough oh no because I'm a piece of [ __ ]
and I am now realizing that the only way
I can pull out of the lease is uh if I
if I kill him find a replacement and I'm
now realizing that I won't have the
funds for how expensive the apartment is
so
um I don't know how to go about telling
my best friend slash roommate that I'm
not going to be living with him and that
um a potential random will be living
with him oh P confrontation so
um I was wondering if you guys had any
suggestions on how I should go about
doing that but um time's a crunch so uh
appreciate you guys take it easy well I
already packed this stuff look at all
the background dude that is insane
is wrong dude yeah he signed it didn't
have the money and also didn't read the
least dude what the [ __ ] no wonder your
mustaches don't like your [ __ ] self
trying to get away even your stash is
trying to get away from you man yeah
dude what is going on well I mean that's
bad but I feel for you [ __ ] spilled
milk but let me be clear you spilled so
much [ __ ] milk yeah it's crazy it's
because of professional here's what you
can do here's what you can do go to your
friend tell them this I know it's hard
because you don't like confrontation but
you tell him this and then when he gets
so mad when he inevited inevitably gets
so mad yeah because you [ __ ] up and
now he's got to live with a stranger
right you're wrong really screwed his
experience up okay you [ __ ] ruined
his [ __ ] life dude it's supposed to
be so cool to go to college you ruined
that you [ __ ] ruined your best
friend's gonna get some [ __ ]
non-speaking English-speaking [ __ ]
guy that he can't even communicate with
and he [ __ ] his thought he'd have his
best friend yeah I thought he'd
literally have his best friend from
childhood yeah but instead he got some
other [ __ ] guy uh there's gonna be 50
or some [ __ ]
um but yeah go when it whenever he gets
so mad because he's gonna get so [ __ ]
mad go like this oh man no I know I
[ __ ] up yeah for sure no I know do
that that is so funny man start he will
think you're a big idiot and he'll start
with like oh man I know I [ __ ] up so
bad bro like oh God like start that way
how could you do this yeah but start
before you even say oh man you're
[ __ ] messed up I'm sorry dude I
didn't want I don't even know how to
tell you but so dumb just like never
stop annihilating yourself yeah yeah
and do that because that's what idiots
do yes because yeah yeah dude you handle
it like a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] you
explained it you took ownership which is
great I mean kinda he hasn't even told
his buddy yet but he told him he said
he's like I'm a piece of [ __ ] he's gonna
tell his buddy because he's got to tell
us about it because if he doesn't one
day his buddy's gonna [ __ ] wake up
and there's gonna be some 50 year old
[ __ ] dude I mean imagine if he didn't
tell her oh dude don't even tell him and
then suddenly there's this guy named Sid
you know yep 57 year old what the [ __ ]
who are you Sid it calls your friend
it's gonna pick up no I know oh man
Homer Simpson doll you know dude that's
insane man wow that's a good wait wait
wait uh I think that we need to stop for
a second okay
and a grill his ass even harder okay
just for a moment because
he didn't
ask what the rent was going to be yeah
yeah are you [ __ ] the biggest idiot
in the world or
yeah the biggest idiot in the world not
only did you not read the least you
didn't ask anyone how much it was going
to be imagine looking at only a
seven-year-old has that imagine looking
at the the thing and being like like
after you already agreed and you signed
it yeah like okay so he's like so your
part is whatever it is he's like foreign
money like the money that is you're
saying every month right yeah oh my okay
okay
I mean okay cool all right let me uh
yeah he's like let me uh all right uh uh
let me yeah
you know just such a [ __ ] idiot uh I
gotta uh
yeah dude so it's gonna be two thousand
twenty two two thousand dollars a month
uh okay
let me uh
I gotta that's cool that's cool but let
me um I got a [ __ ] there's something I
needed to do
[Laughter]
I gotta call uh my I gotta call my my
mom
oh [ __ ] are you cool with uh living with
someone else that's a stranger
insane how do you not look at that man
ask how much how much the second month
rent the guy was like oh I need your
second month rent he was like wait
I already paid though yeah like just
because he thinks one month is it yeah
yeah I already paid it all up front
what because you said the deposit or
whatever yeah that's right that was the
deposit now I need next month deposit is
for all of it right the deposit is for
me staying here yeah for a year
all right let me just making this about
his failure to understand the out clause
what's up
you're right right that's that's way
down the line
he's like I'm a piece of [ __ ] for not
understanding for not reading the thing
the Clause like how I have to get out of
it right right is that what he said yeah
your [ __ ] up is way before that yeah
imagine going to a supermarket and you
getting groceries and you [ __ ] put on
a thing and they're like okay that'll be
a hundred dollars and he's just like oh
[ __ ] right yeah or you go to buy a
[ __ ] like a cigarette cigarettes
that's however much it is
oh dude what you mean this costs money
too this is uh where's the free stuff
yeah yeah I mean that's that's
unacceptably stupid to not ask how much
your rent is well uh all right look uh
you guys uh appreciate you uh and also
I'll be in uh New York I will be in uh
Lakeland Florida and also be in San
Diego and also
um
Chicago [ __ ]
um and Austin and Midland Texas and
Sugarland Texas New Orleans Providence
Rhode Island
uh Kansas City Missouri Springfield
Tulsa Minneapolis Columbus anyway a lot
of different places chrisley.com go over
there and that'll be great and get your
tickets go to get your merch at uh
Lifeline what is merch
lifelinemerch.com I mean what do you
what are you doing
what are you doing
so
weird and not good acting in a movie
one on one obsession with your boy Mr
math Dalia
book it Tuesdays and Thursdays 1 35 30
Pacific time we thought
oh what else you got that's it dude
that's it okay yeah and for the merch go
to lifelinemerch.com somehow some way
somehow my brother keeps on forgetting
that even though it's the most [ __ ]
straightforward website merch.com oh I
just don't know why we have two
different ones the watch lifeline.com
and then also Lifeline merch that's just
a really straightforward website it's
lifelines.com life rips
[Music]